we begin with New Revelations from
Britney Spears about her conservatorship
in a now private audio message posted on
YouTube last night in the alleged
message from Spears she said she felt
like a robot while working so hard
during her 13-year conservatorship which
ended in November
honestly still to this day don't know
what really I did but the punishment of
my father I wasn't able to you know
see anyone or like anything and you have
to imagine none of it made sense to me
it was all basically set up there was no
drugs in my system no alcohol nothing it
was pure abuse
and and I haven't haven't even really
shared even half of it
in the audio clip Spears appears angry
at her mother for not helping her
overnight Lynn Spears said on Instagram
I have never and will never turn my back
on you but this talk is for you and me
only eye to eye in private for the
record when spirit's father Jamie was
suspended from the conservatorship last
fall his attorney issued a statement
saying Mr Spears loves her
unconditionally for 13 years he has
tried to do what is in her best interest
I'm not sure everybody agrees with that
I mean things have definitely broken
down as a family when you're issuing
love statements to your child through a
lawyer yes exactly and then the mom
responds on Instagram I do wish that
they could talk about it privately she
put it up it was 22 minutes long she has
since deleted it she said a lot of
people have offered her money to do an
interview including Oprah I don't know
about other people but I know Oprah
didn't offer her any money to do an
interview but people do want to hear
from her but it is sad to see how the
family drama and dynamic is playing out
and just as she's put out this song
without John where she could have turned
a Paige yes it feels like they're always
coming back to this exactly yes